hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and as the mha
manga enters what appears to be its
final stage and as the story is
seemingly coming to its epic climax
people have been asking me whether i
think that a big time skip will happen
at the end of the story or if there
might be a time skip and then a sequel
kind of like naruto shipuden in this
video i will break down what a my hero
time skip could look like who would live
who would die and where the story would
go from here the mha time skip has the
potential to be one of the craziest of
all time so let's get into it you guys
know the drill if you enjoyed these
videos and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps with
that youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
way to directly support the channel and
it's a very important thing on youtube
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned so with horikoshi
confirming that the current events in
the manga are part of the final act of
the story and with some speculating that
the manga could end as early as this
year a lot of mha fans are kind of
freaking out about what's going to
happen next is this really the end for
boku no hero like it's actually over or
is there going to be some form of
continuation regardless of what happens
in this final act it's hard to say for
sure because at the end of the day it's
up to horikoshi to decide but if you're
wondering whether mha is profitable and
whether they would make money if they
kept going the answer is a definite yes
the manga has sold over 65 million
copies to date and it was the fifth
best-selling manga of 2021 so last year
on top of that the anime the movies and
the merch make a ton of money so as long
as horikoshi is willing to continue the
story in some way he will definitely
have every opportunity to do so mha is
certainly not about to get cancelled by
the publisher or anything like that and
even if horikoshi decided that he didn't
want to keep working on the manga
personally the publisher could still
continue it with another mangaka as was
done with dragon ball super and early
boruto as long as horikoshi agrees of
course so far in mha our biggest time
skip was only a couple of months but
could we see a time skip of several
years that completely changes the world
and the characters i think that this is
not only possible but even likely we
can't forget that the whole mha series
starts off with an older deku telling us
the story of how he became the greatest
hero so the idea of seeing deku as an
adult who has become the greatest hero
is already baked into the narrative the
only question is what kind of time skip
will this be will it be a time skip that
takes place just like in the final
chapter of the manga as a sort of
epilogue or will it be a time skip that
leads into a continuation of the story
like with naruto shipuden a lot of this
depends on how the current war arc
against the villains will turn out if
all the major villains are either killed
or captured in this war arc then they
won't pose a threat after the time skip
and any possible continuation would need
to introduce completely new villains
that is certainly not impossible since
the fact that quirks are becoming more
powerful with each passing generation is
well established in the story so we
could totally see a younger villain with
an overpowered quirk emerging as a major
threat but if some of the major villains
that have already been introduced
survive and evade capture at the end of
the war arc then they could also become
a threat after the time skip and they
would likely be even stronger as time
goes by i personally believe that this
war arc will bring an end to all the
major villain plot points in the story i
don't think over one will survive this
battle in fact i think he might even be
killed by shigaraki himself dabi may
also die just because his obsession with
endeavour has completely clouded his
judgment and common sense and many of
the other villains could end up in
tartarus over the years there's been a
lot of speculation about whether or not
toga could ever be rehabilitated but her
recent actions in the manga suggest that
she has no intention of abandoning the
villain life so my guess is that after
the war arc she will end up in prison or
better yet a psychiatric facility of
some kind kind of like the mha version
of arkham asylum the biggest question of
course is the fate of shigaraki who is
the single strongest villain at this
point in the story and i don't see any
other villain surpassing him any time
soon shigaraki could be killed in the
final battle he could be defeated but
somehow survive and get away or he could
redeem himself by turning on all for one
and the villains and becoming
tenkoshimura once again the third
scenario is definitely my personal least
favorite because trying to turn
shigeraki into a good guy after
everything he's done just seems a bit
corny however i do believe that deku
will try to do exactly that
deku's biggest weakness has always been
his desire to save everyone and has
believed that even the worst villains
can be safe he has explicitly stated
that he wants to try and save
tenkoshimura who is still trapped
somewhere inside the supervillain known
as tomura shigaraki i say that this is
deku's biggest weakness because he is
often willing to put himself in danger
and even do reckless things in order to
save other people assuming that
shigaraki won't just magically become a
good guy it is possible that he will try
to make deku think that he is still
tenko deep inside in order to trick deku
and get him to lower his guard shigaraki
could then use this as an opportunity to
attack and eliminate deku once and for
all now of course spoiler alert we know
that deku won't die he is a shonen
protagonist and this is the story of how
he became the greatest hero so even if
shigaraki tricks him and his life is in
danger someone will show up to rescue
him i think that all might may sacrifice
his life in order to protect deku from
shigaraki's sneak attack and then
almight's tragic sacrifice will finally
teach deku a valuable lesson some
villains just can't be saved and you
have to do what it takes to protect
other people from these villains deku
will then step up and kill shigaraki in
order to protect the rest of the world
at least that's what i hope will happen
and we won't have a cop out like with
aang and firelord ozai but that's a
topic for a whole nother video there
have been many many death flags for all
might throughout the course of the
series so if he were to die in the final
battle his lasting legacy would play a
big role in the subsequent time skip
post time skip deku would become more
mature and less idealistic and i can
even see him being a lot more stern and
serious at least at first glance i
definitely think that some big hero
deaths will occur during this war arc
especially among the older generations
like all might and endeavour a hero
student may also die but that's less
likely in my opinion also i think that
class 1b students are much more likely
to die than the mains in class 1a so
good luck to our boy nato monoma now the
time skip could also show us what the ua
would look like several years into the
future with a new generation of kids
like arie and coda becoming the new
students at ua and with some of our
favorite current students potentially
becoming teachers as i mentioned earlier
quirks keep getting stronger and
stronger with each passing generation so
we can expect to see some incredible and
overpowered quirks from the new
generation of ua students and i can
totally see deku becoming a teacher at
ua at least doing it part time while
also being a hero i think that this
would be a really cool way for deco to
honor all might's legacy by following in
his footsteps and i think that it would
be hilarious to see deku trying to be a
strict and serious teacher at first but
then despite his best efforts his soft
and kind nature inevitably emerges in
hilarious ways it's possible that
multiple current ua students could end
up as future ua teachers although some
are definitely better candidates than
others like i think ochakotsuyu momo and
kirishima would all make great teachers
but bakugo and minata
not so much although bakugo as a teacher
at ua would be extremely entertaining to
watch
but now for the most important aspect of
all
shipping who will end up together after
a lengthy time skip to be honest there
is really only one ship that i am
personally confident about and that is
deku x ochaco like i'm 99 sure that this
ship will be canon by the time the story
ends and that it will be featured in any
potential time skip the relationship
between deku and ochako has evolved in
meaningful ways over the course of the
story especially in these last few arcs
and so you can definitely see them
smoothly transitioning into becoming a
couple don't get me wrong they could
still end up just being friends but i
just have a hunch that this ship will
set sail i know that some people really
ship deku with toga but i think the most
recent arc in the story has kind of made
it clear that this relationship will not
work and of course deku's relationship
with mei hatsume never evolved beyond
just a meme so ochako is the only viable
option in my opinion other ships in the
series have had a bit of development
like momo x todoroki aizawa x miss joke
and mineta x fbi watch list but there's
not that much there other than fan
speculation i also think that all my ex
deku's mom would be an amazing ship i'm
all for it but it can only happen if all
might actually survives and if we get a
proper explanation for what's going on
with deku's father i'm definitely hoping
that horikoshi will explain the father
situation soon because he did say that
he would do it eventually now the story
is progressing quickly towards its
climax and there is still nothing about
deku's dad as of the making of this
video and i hope this changes soon so
the way i see it a post timeskip mha
world would feature deku as the world's
greatest hero who also moonlights as a
somewhat insecure ua teacher he and
ochako will end up together and the next
generation of ua students will feature
arie kota and a bunch of new kids with
overpowered quirks all might will either
be a legend who sacrificed his life in
the final battle against shigaraki or
deku's new daddy bakugo would make one
of the worst and yet most entertaining
ua teachers ever he and todoroki will
definitely end up as top tier pro heroes
and mineta will be the pro hero with the
most restraining orders against him oh
and meteo meteo would make an amazing ua
teacher and he's gonna definitely be one
of the strongest heroes meteo is just
such an awesome guy and his quirk
actually required him to work extremely
hard in order to master it so i think
that meteo is the perfect person to help
a bunch of kids with overpowered quirks
learn how to actually control them and
use them properly finally miruko will
become my wife the end let me know what
you guys think is there going to be a
big time skip in mha now that the story
seems to be reaching its climax and if
there is a time skip will it just be
like a quick epilogue or will we get a
post-time skip continuation like naruto
shipuden who will become the strongest
pro heroes who will be the villains of
the future who will end up together
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below you guys know the
drill if you enjoyed these videos and
you want to see more in the future just
leave a quick like and comment it really
helps with that youtube algorithm and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet remember
that subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
but very real way of supporting the
channel directly you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury he is an
absolute mad lad and a disciple of lord
twego himself and i can't forget all of
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
alpha sigma pate heffa the red-haired
fox hinokamien water the toasted chi
corey mcgowan the fallen chosen spidey
life tinel tungsten tarkis and baked
buddhist finally thank you also to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh on hell crews alicia
octor bonnie parks fat boy games kaido
might be a duck jessica rabbit ollyvania
and mando if you guys enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you